The Bible says the Old Testament New
Testament, which is pretty powerful.
I know people misinterpret itself,
but it's ancient tax.
The people that are there like,
well,
you read Zinky like three
burning wheels land.
There's a blue from in over 10
it gives me something to take.
I take it and give him the full
data of the plan that that, that,
that the genetics has been infested in.
God must destroy everyone.
That's an alien story. Oh, it's 100%
but that's what they always talk about.
There was talking about
that being an alien story.
That's why one of the primary stories
when they, when we talk about the Bible,
Ezekiel's vision, a wheel within a wheel
that they always thought of, you read it,
it says floating off the ground and
the Hebrew and the King James is pretty
clear to floating comes a thing
with a crystal from it over its head
and then the face of shifting different
creatures. It's like a video screen. Well,
if you think about how long it
would take for an alien to get here,
it really only makes sense that unless
they have a constant basis in a robot
they visit, or if they, if
they came by themselves,
they came by themselves
a long fucking time ago.
Like if they were able to
make interstellar travel
like two, 3000 years ago,
which is not that big of a leap.
If you think about us 3000 years from now,
we probably can do something like that,
right?
So if they were doing that 3000 years
ago and they found human beings,
and these are the stories that we have,
these stories like a Zeke,
you'll and like,
uh,
there's a bunch of different ancient
stories about contact with the skies,
you know, the, uh, changing to tabulation.
Yeah. There's a world government,
the beach is 50 feet tall. It shifts.
Everyone can see it the same time.
It's a Hologram.
And you've got these digital systems.
If you don't go along when you
can't buy her shell, people say, oh,
that's not real, but it's manifesting
and then go 2000 years. In the future.
They have advanced technology.
They don't send people anymore
and now they send aliens.
If you go back to the old days,
it was actually some sort of humanoid
or a large thing like all the Zachariae
sitch and shit. The covers and Sumerian
texts. Exactly. That's what I'm,
I make sense. That's what all those
guys are telling you. Like Avatar,
James Camera's definitely dialed
in. It's like, no, we're there jack.
They're jacking him.
Well,
it makes sense that if there was a visitor
to this planet five 10 15,000 years
ago,
if there was maybe more,
maybe if there was a visitor hundreds
of thousands of years ago that actually
did genetic experiments on lower hominids.
If that was really the case,
it makes sense that their technology,
would it increase far more rapid,
but let's go pass that.
Obviously scientists like to plant things,
gardeners like to plan things and,
but that's Joe.
That's exactly what the globalist believe
is that maybe they're just aware of
what the fuck's going on.
There was powerless as we are.
If they're reading more and more,
they only put soulless people in
charge who are compartmentalized.
Nobody else knows who will carry the shop.
But we're able, because we're advanced,
look at this because let, let's just get
down to brass tax tax. I love tax law. No,
Joe, you just said it instead of
some weird dumb preacher, you know,
and in Alabama, not bashing Alabama
sang stuff. You'd get mad at this.
Don't look at watch. So demonized. Look
at why it's demonized. Think about that,
right?
Think about how it shares.
Okay.
That there's no reality and god creates
a whole new virtual reality, gives light,
does all of it, and then
his genetic experiment by
rogue elements gets involved.
It's all right there.
When you actually look at it and you
expand on it and you're like, oh my God,
this is like beyond a science fiction
book. And so it's the obvious thing.
That's why they keep telling
us, oh look, Piltdown man,
all this fake stuff. No, Joe,
they did an accelerated immunogenic.
They're doing Jewish now. Something new.
They did an accelerated immunogenic
program on this planet and humanity.
What? What does the Bible start with?
Pick as we are made in the image of God.
What does that mean?
We don't have God's knowledge.
We don't have God's advancement. We're
the image. Well, what does an image?
It's a scan. It's numbers. It's
the genetics. It's the potential.
So we are the aliens. Joe and everybody
already knows this. We are the aliens.
Do you think that we are a
product of alien intervention?
They took these lower hominids and they
accelerated their evolution by applying
their genetics.
Okay.
Do you know we, here's the deal.
They say we're 97% chimpanzee,
but then they actually get
into the deeper genetics.
We're closer to pigs are Rach show.
I think that this was an
environment built for us.
We're the master genetic program
and they're are all subsets of us.
Just for a backstory. Uh, and that's
what the loveless thing. Yeah,
but do you think that
the aliens created us?
Like this is like one of the primary
what? The elite beliefs, right?
The elders are biological.
Android's the grayish and then there's
other systems going on and no one knows
because it's all warfare, psychological
stuff. No one knows. The truth is it's,
it's virtual reality once you get to that
level. So no one knows. We just don't,
we're advanced. But we are, and I'm
not just answering a rifle. Powerful.
The globalists are obsessed. The elites
are obsessed because she reportedly,
obviously humans are pretty fricking cool.
We've got some big giant mission
and maybe that's a program,
I don't know that we're
like pretty super advanced,
but you can't put something out like
the Spartans were when their kids were
seven, they throw him out
for two years in the woods.
You can't just put something out
like, like, like, like liberals.
You give her very everything.
There's a little hassles show.
This is like bootcamp
and training and they,
so they had the testis and do all this.
And basically this planet
is what the people say.
It's a big testing ground for other things
that are going to come. And we are at,
we are God. And I don't mean
I'm God, I'm already God.
I've achieved godhood cause you could
see that potential on your shelf and and
the,
and the,
and the lower level ELLs will tell you
that because they already know you're bad
ash.
But if they can trick a tadpole,
it's going to grow into Godzilla to
they'll kill itself. They're winning.
So you show some of the cash.
The elves are a test
on us to attack us and,
and and she the survival of the fittest
but they're nothing. They're like,
well by by the time we've achieved
conscious and we look back and go,
we're not going to look at it that
because I think when you jumped the next
level, there's even bigger war
going on. What's the biggest war?
Consciousness of the universe is
an interdimensional spacecraft.
Beyond that then looks like a
comment from my research and it has,
it has its head as its corona.
That's consciousness consciousness.
He carries evil in the tail end. The
consciousness has a location. No,
there is this giant
consciousness. God, okay.
Swimming in a giant system of survival,
a fitness that God has created a test
God self. Okay, looks like a comment.
So you've got God's conscious
and all the good things,
the knowledge going forward, but God
knows that everybody has to be tested.
So the tail goes out and at the
end of the tail is basically evil.
That's why Christ says,
get behind me, Satan.
And it's always trying to test God
and infiltrate up into it to sabotage.
Damn.
If they do pull the plug in.
This podcast is a good way
to end this motherfucker.
I of your burnout one is fit. Oh, I'm not,
I'm just saying it 1,300 and something.
If the fucking governments come in,
but shell,
they love [inaudible]. You guys have
been talking about aliens so much, dude,
trust me.
This is not the move.
Biggest youtube videos of all is that
the move to talk about aliens as much as
possible.
They allow me to shut up,
let me call over children's
program one bs alien stuff.
Or were they come out of space?
It's interdimensional Eddie. Well,
when you say alien to tell you that
you're talking to them, the Kadian,
that's what it sounds like.
Literally believe they're in
contact with these things. Well,
maybe they are probably to
describe what you saw DMT and you,
you tell us you have these experiences
where thoughts become patterns.
They become like geometric patterns
that are moving through space and they
change and shift, but they're letting you
know that they know all your bullshit.
They see right through you and
they want the want is creation.
They want you to relax.
Yes. There is a lot of that.
There's a lot of thought as creation.
Yes, but but with the only oh, relaxed.
Just so you don't struggle. No one to
call them aliens though. What I saw,
I never referred to them as a,
but that's the term.
Everyone knows not of this world. None
of our average thing. I would listen,
I would think it was aliens.
If it woke me up in the middle of
the night and it took me a board,
a ship and that's what I experienced,
how it'd be 100% convinced that I went
to an alien spaceship and I talked to
these things,
the differences,
how it was like to smoke it and
then laid back and then experience.
That is like I expected that progression
of events but if I woke up in the
middle of the night I was going to take
a leak and a a light shone down to the
bathroom and they stuck me through
the window. It took me a board,
a space ship and I saw the exact same
thing that I saw when I was high on DMT.
I'd be 100% convinced that I was in
contact with aliens. The different,
the only difference is how I got there.
Like I got there through a drug.
I got there through smoking,
something that's produced by the human
brain that I knew it was pretty safe.
No one's ever died of it.
I'm like, let's what happens?
And all that goes back to everyone
I've talked to in mash groups taking
particularly Iowasca yeah. They have
group events and see the same things.
They hear the same thing. Yes. Yeah.
Which is the psychic connection.
But it's beyond that. You could argue
a one person's a psychic leader.
They projected everybody else's minds.
But who's projecting that into them?
So that's the only way it's out. This,
this is one of the Pentagon. It will,
it might not be someone projecting
anything into your mind.
It might be your new found ability
to perceive things that you could.
The way I look at it, it's like, no, I
agree, but why are they all 43 people?
You know, in Costa Rica,
all shooting aliens.